(upbeat music)
- As people are gonna figure
out in about seven seconds
your accent is not Hungarian.
So what brings a guy like
you to a country like this?
- Well, I see the political
future of conservatism
in America is being worked out
here in Hungary, in Budapest.
And that's fascinating to me.
I first came to
Budapest around 2018
on a book tour but also I came
a year later to do research
for my book "Live Not By Lies"
which is about the message
that people who survived
communism in Europe,
Soviet communism,
the message they have
for us in the West today
about the new softer
totalitarianism that
they see emerging.
And I thought it was
really exaggerated
when they first started
telling me this about,
I dunno, eight, nine years ago.
But the more I listened to them,
I'm talking about
America, these immigrants,
the more I listened to them,
the more I realized they
were seeing something
that was completely oblivious,
that we Americans
were oblivious to.
And so I came to travel
throughout the former Soviet
Block, Hungary, Poland,
other countries to talk to
those who had stayed behind
and were dissidents to find
out what do we need to know.
And they're so sensible
in this part of the world
and they really know to use
a phrase what time it is.
So I thought, you know what?
I want to live here and learn
what I can from these people
and try to bring the
lessons that I've learned
about politics and about
culture and the fight we're in
to try to make it better known
to my own people
back in America.
Plus it's just a
great place to live.
- Well the view ain't
bad from up here.
- Ain't bad.
What is it specifically though
about Hungarians or
Hungarian culture
that seems to be leading this?
Because there's obviously
plenty of other countries
bordering right here that
maybe aren't doing it
quite as well.
There seems to be something
happening right here.
- The difference is Viktor
Orban, the prime minister here.
You don't hear this at
all in the American media.
He's demonized this
sort of fascist
who was an authoritarian
crushing his country.
That was the received
opinion I had
the first time I
came here in 2018.
I was here to speak at a
conference on religious liberty.
After the conference was over,
we were told that
the prime minister
would like to see meet
some of the speakers.
I went in there thinking there's
gonna be a meet and greet,
hake hands with him hear if
you can phrases, and off we go.
That man spent 90
minutes talking to us
taking our questions
in good English.
He was warm, he was funny.
And you could tell he had really
thought about these things,
the Americans there,
we couldn't believe it.
You would never hear that
from any of our
politicians left and right
the ability to
think on your feet
and to have thought
deeply about these issues.
Viktor Orban, I've come
to find out since then,
I've met him a couple more times
and read more about him
now that I live here.
I mean, he's everywhere.
Here's a man who is
a real visionary.
And Americans just
don't know about it
because our media and the
Republican establishment
are keeping him at arm's length.
But when I invite
Americans over,
I meet like meet you
coming over here.
If you meet Orban or if you
spend any time in Hungary
you realize he is not
and this country is
not what we're told.
And in fact, this guy,
I think, sees the future
for the right.
- It's so interesting
because the way the media
permeates everything, even
if you somehow intellectually
know something's not true,
I find sometimes you have
to see it for yourself.
I told you, I just spent 15
minutes with him by chance.
We walked over there and
he was able to say hi,
friendly, warm and
just immediately
just wanted to tell me
why he loves this country
and in essence to
distill it down,
he basically said
it's our country
and we don't wanna
be told how to live.
And I thought, man, we
could use a little of that.
- Absolutely.
- In America.
- I was at his speech at CPAC
both in Dallas last year and
here in Hungary recently.
And his speech
really does contain
the things that we
American conservatives need
in order to revitalize
conservatism here
in our country.
He was talking about how the
virus, he calls it a virus,
of wokeness, gender ideology,
of open borders migration,
all of it is designed to
dissolve the nation state
and to dissolve peoples.
If we are going to hold on
to what makes us who we are,
we need to stand up against it,
call it out for what it is,
and don't be fooled by it.
The thing that Orban sees
that so many American
conservatives don't
is that the left has
colonized every institution
of civil society.
When I talked to
Hungarians about
what's happened to our
military, to the CIA,
to big business and to
every other institution,
they really can't believe it.
Orban saw a long time ago
that this was
happening and he knew
that the only way
traditional conservatives
could stand up do what
the NGOs, George Soros
and all the other wokesters
and open borders
people were doing
was to use politics
in an aggressive way.
We don't see that
in our country.
Ron DeSantis is the
only one in our country
at the senior level of
Republican leadership
who seems to get that.
- Do you think that can be
expanded throughout America?
I mean, we talked about it a
bit at the event last night.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But you know, I'm living
it literally living it
in Florida and it
changed my life.
I had to move 3000
miles from California
to Florida, I see
it happen here.
Do you think that can
be replicated properly
in America or our politics
to calcify at this point?
- You know, it can, but
we have to be careful.
I mean, we were talking
last night, you and I,
about Israel and Hungary
and their success stories.
One of the things that
makes their politics
play out the way
they do is they have
an underlying sense
of national unity.
I mean, here in Hungary,
it is a homogeneous country
ethnically and culturally
and that matters.
I mean, they're of course,
there are really harsh
political disputes here
but ultimately they
have this sense
of this is where the tribe
was, the Magyar tribe.
We've been here for
a thousand years
and we have to keep
our country going.
The United States is a
much more diverse place.
And there's nothing
wrong with that.
It's just it is what it
is and it's why you can't
just pick up Orbanism
and plug it into America.
But what we can do
and what we have to do
is unite our country,
America, around the principles
of the Constitution, you know,
and not to be afraid to
talk about the importance
of free speech and things
that are in the Bill of Rights
that are under constant
attack by the woke.
We can defend those things,
but we also have to understand
that using the standard
methods of defense
which is what the Republican
Party has been offering
ain't gonna work anymore
because things changed
in the Great Awakening,
all of the institutions
are lined up against us.
Yeah. When you see what
DeSantis is doing in Florida
by going in, taking on woke
capitalism with Disney,
and trying to get DEI and
wokeness out of the schools
that's pure Orban and it's the
only thing that's gonna work.
- Yeah.
Where do you see
the pushback here?
I've been trying to
figure out, you know,
it's very easy
for me to diagnose
what's going on with
our left in America.
It's sort of, it really
has become radicalized
and I wish there was a good left
that we could debate with.
Honestly, it just
doesn't seem to exist.
What's the sort of
temperature on that here?
- Yeah, I hesitate
to speak too boldly
because I don't
speak Hungarian yet,
and so I miss a lot of the
nuance in the local debates
but generally speaking,
the left in Hungary
is run by a man named Gyurcsany,
who at the time of
the fall of communism
was ahead of the
Communist Youth League.
He's still the big guy in
left-wing politics here.
And by the way, seven years
after the fall of communism
this guy became one of the
richest men in Hungary.
Funny how that happened.
- You don't say, you don't say.
- Yeah and so a lot of the
people who remember communism
they're totally on Orban's side,
because he was a very brave
student, anti-communist leader.
You could go on YouTube
and find this video
of a speech he gave in 1988
as communism was falling.
They were rebury a man
who was a communist leader
in 1956 at the time
of the Soviet invasion
but he was a patriot, and
the Soviets hanged him,
Imre Nagy was his name,
Orban as a student leader,
he's got a mullet and all that.
He's totally '80s.
He gave this very brave speech
in which he told the Soviets
to get the hell out
of their country.
This was the time when communism
was still ruling this country,
and that became the basis for
his later political career.
So the left today in
Hungary is still run
by this old fashioned communist,
but they've smoothed things out
and now they're
property bureaucrats
meaning they want
rule from Brussels,
they want open borders,
they want George Soros
and all the whole package.
The lucky thing for this country
is they're completely
disorganized.
I was here last year,
2022, for the election
which Orban and his Fidesz party
won overwhelming a landslide.
And they weren't
supposed to win.
Living here in Hungary,
knowing Hungarians,
talking to ordinary Hungarians
in the bar, in the
coffee shop, the taxi,
many of them complained about
this or that about Orban.
Anybody after 12 years in
power's gonna have that.
- Sure.
- But in the end,
it all came down to but of
course I'm gonna vote for him.
Have you seen the left?
Because they're
completely incompetent.
- Yeah.
- They had this guy
who was their, a
guy named Marki-Zay.
He was their standard
bear in 2022.
He gave this comment.
He said, we're the
true diverse coalition.
We have communist and
fascist in the coalition
which was true, but you're
not supposed to say that.
- Coming to our Democrat party.
- Yeah, get this, Dave.
The media, the Western media
did not report that at all.
They would only come
to Budapest, talk
to Budapest liberals
and they totally
missed everything.
They thought that
because Orban was opposed
to NATO's policy in
Ukraine that, ah,
the Hungarians are
gonna throw 'em out.
No, he spoke for them.
They don't want war.
- So when I chatted with him
just briefly a moment ago
I asked him about how
he deals with the media
and he kind of laughed it off.
Like it seems clear to me
he simply does not care.
Do you think that really
is the prescription
for all of this?
That we need more political
leaders who just don't care and-
- Yes. Yes.
That's it.
He's so confident
and he's so smart.
That's the thing.
He's not a crude, brutish guy.
He says what's on his mind.
- He had a smile on his
face the entire time.
It was so contrasted with
what you hear of the guy.
- Exactly.
And he's a brilliant man.
He knows what he believes,
and he's also ready to fight.
He fights constantly.
Some Hungarians say maybe he's
too quick to start a fight
but I tell you, I'd
rather have that
than the Republicans we have
who are willing to roll
over at every turn.
And as much as Viktor
Orban loves Donald Trump,
the huge difference
between Orban and Trump is
Orban believes a lot of
the things Trump does,
but he also knows how to turn
those beliefs into policy.
He's got discipline and
he's got political skills.
This is why I look to DeSantis,
and I try to tell my
Hungarian friends,
this DeSantis is the
successor to Orban
or the American
version of Orban.
- Yeah. Interesting.
All right, so one more for you.
As a new guy in this country,
what would you tell people
that are watching this going?
Boy, I should probably spend
a little more time there.
- I would say, come over here.
There's no substitute for
actually coming to Hungary
and seeing for yourself.
When Americans come over,
I tell them one of the first
things you need to know
is the international media and
the Washington establishment
treat Hungary the same way
conservatives are treated
in the United States.
You know, you're nothing
but a bunch of bigots
and backwards deplorables.
When you actually
get here to Hungary,
you see, it ain't true.
It's not true at all.
And the more time
you spend here,
you realize how blessedly
normal this country is.
Low crime, you know,
they have descent
and they struggle here.
It's a normal
country in that sense
but it's also a stable country.
And one of the reasons almost
alone among European capitals
that Budapest is so
safe is because Orban
would not allow open migration.
I remember going to Paris
in the summer of 2021.
I was here in Budapest
on a fellowship.
I went to Paris on a book tour
and everybody was afraid then
because there was
lots of Palestinian
and in Islamic radicalism
going on, anti-Semitic attacks.
People in Paris were
all talking about
is this the start
of a civil war?
And I realized, oh my God,
that the Orban was right.
If you allow open borders,
and you allow people
who hate your society,
and who don't want to integrate
to come in, this
is what happens.
They're never gonna get
rid of that problem.
Come here to Hungary,
learn how they do it,
and go back to America
with a sense of vision.
Tucker Carlson got
this vision Dave.
He came here in 2021,
saw for himself how
different this country was
to the way it's presented
in the American media.
And he changed the narrative
at the grassroots
level about Hungary.
We saw what happened to Tucker.
There are a lot of
powerful people in America
who don't want
American conservatives
to pay any attention to Hungary
much less come here and
learn any lessons from it.
I'm here to tell you,
and I'm glad you're here.
It's not what they say.
Come see for yourself.
- Yeah.
And I suspect we have not
heard the last from Tucker.
- No, no, no.
Please God.
- Roger, it was
great to see you.
- Thanks Dave.
Yeah.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.